welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Professor David Cameron a professor
of political science at Yale and the
director of the program in European
Union studies at the Macmillan Center
professor Cameron teaches courses on
European politics and the European Union
he has written extensively about the
impact of trade openness on government
and with respect to the EU about the
initiative to complete the internal
market the operation of the European
monetary system and the enlargement of
the EU professor Cameron joins us today
to talk about the EU and the European
economics crisis welcome professor
Cameron Thank You Marilyn it's good to
be here so let's do a little crash
course in EU 101 what is the European
Union okay the European Union is a union
of states there are now 27 states it
began with France Germany Italy Belgium
Netherlands and Luxembourg backed in
1952 in the Coal and Steel Community and
over the years it's expanded its
functions and it's expanded its
membership so that now it's 27 states
and probably within a decade or so
there'll be 33 34 35 States so it's a
very large organization it's more than
an international organization it has a
dense array of institutions at the
supranational level of Parliament
Commission Council of Ministers so it's
a it's a unique entity mm-hmm like the
United States Europe is facing a pretty
bleak economic forecast how does what
the EU is facing similar or dissimilar
to what the United States is going
through it's facing the same crisis it's
a global crisis in a global financial
crisis
and it's having a very severe effect in
Europe there's a very large contraction
going on in Europe increase in
unemployment as here and the major
problem is the Europeans really haven't
as yet responded as aggressively to the
contraction as the American
administration or the British
administration of Prime Minister Brown
okay and in a letter you wrote appearing
in the Financial Times you state that
Europe needs a much larger stimulus how
much more do you think is needed and why
well in in November back in November the
European Commission which is the
technical civil service of the European
Union drafted a plan for a stimulus of
200 billion euros which would be about
one and a half percent of GDP now you
compare that with the Obama stimulus of
787 billion dollars which is about five
and a half percent of our gdp so the
European stimulus is about a third the
size of ours most of it would come from
the member states themselves because the
EU doesn't really have very much fiscal
capacity now that was agreed in December
but i think it's the case and i think
most observers including the IMF the
oecd and the European Union staff itself
realized that the contraction is getting
worse and worse and the Europeans have
been reluctant to go any further than
they have gone as of December so they
are in a situation where they are not
doing what they could be doing and what
I think they should be doing and but I'm
just one voice of many who have been
saying this the Obama administration and
the IMF have been arguing for a much
larger stimulus in the
in the EU and there is a great deal of
reluctance unfortunately to do that the
cost is the contraction will go on
longer it'll be deeper they'll be later
to recover and the unemployment rate
will be higher as a result why do you
think they rejected the greater stimulus
well there was a good deal of debate in
the g20 the g20 the group of 20 is a
group of states countries that gathered
together the g7 which is the US and
canada and italy in germany and britain
and france and japan and then russia
added on as the g8 you add in a few more
countries you get to the g20 it includes
a number of developing or middle-income
countries China India Mexico Brazil for
example and the g20 met in London on
April second last week and had a serious
meeting dealing with the all aspects of
the crisis they could agree on the need
for the IMF to have a substantial
increase in its resources which could be
made available to countries having a
balance of payments crisis they could
agree at least in principle on
increasing financial regulation and
there's a perception in Europe that it
was hedge funds it was our financial
system let loose and running rampant
that contributed to this crisis so
there's a major push in Europe
especially for greater regulation what
they couldn't agree on was a larger
stimulus and the US had pushed that
quite hard in the meetings leading up to
the g20 summit meeting with the finance
ministers our treasury secretary had
been over there arguing for a stimulus
supported by IMF analyses and so forth
but the Europeans are very reluctant to
do that for variety of reasons
many of them really aren't canes Ian's
the continental Europeans don't really
buy the notion of canes counter-cyclical
policy they're much more reluctant to
run large budget deficits they have a
commitment in in the eurozone in
particular that is the 16 countries in
the EU that have the euro they have a
commitment not to incur what they call
excessive deficits which our deficits
over three percent of GDP you can't
really do an aggressive stimulus without
violating that rule in the eurozone and
the German government in particular is
very reluctant to support that any such
deficit so there was an agreement prior
to the g20 that the Americans wouldn't
push and and the issue was papered over
so basically nothing was done in terms
of a fiscal stimulus it was the great
from my point of view the great failure
of the g20 meeting that there wasn't a
conservative effort many of the
countries in the world are running very
substantial counter-cyclical policies
designed to pull the world and the
country out of the recession of China's
doing that Japan's doing that Britain's
doing that we're doing that
unfortunately the Europeans aren't and
who that hurts especially I think are
the some of the Europeans themselves in
particular the countries of Central and
Eastern Europe which depend on demand in
markets in Western Europe for the sale
of their goods and they're being hurt
and suffering greatly and several of the
country's Latvia hungry now Romania are
about to have to go two of them have
gone and Romania soon to go to the IMF
for substantial package of emergency
funding
which is a signal of the extent to which
their economies have deteriorated so the
issue is still on the table my sense is
the Europeans will meet in the European
Council which is the group of leaders of
heads of state and government of the EU
the 27 leaders will meet again in june
they met in March and decided not to do
anything they'll meet again in june to
assess their december recovery plan and
my suspicion is they will realize as the
oecd pointed out last week that the
contraction is much more severe than
people thought it would be it's getting
worse europe probably right now as of
the end of the first quarter has 16 or
17 or 18 countries in a recession
simultaneously we've never had such a
broad continent-wide synchronized
recession and my sense is the Europeans
will realize and come to the realization
that they have to do something so the
you painted a pretty bleak picture so
moving forward do you you know what do
you think will happen well I think the
Europeans will I think some of the
Europeans are doing a good job one of
the interesting things is that there are
divergent responses in the EU to the
crisis the Gordon Brown government has
been very aggressive has in some sense
set set the path for other countries in
how to respond it was the first first
substantial stimulus program came out of
Britain the first program to
recapitalize the banks came out of
Britain so Britain is responding
although it will nevertheless have an
unemployment rate around ten percent by
the end of this year some of the
Scandinavian member states are
responding some of the other countries
in Northern Europe such as Belgium and
the net
and Luxembourg are responding the real
foot draggers is I it seems to me our
France and Italy in Spain especially
France and Italy which could be doing
much more than they are doing right now
and my sense is they will decide and
realize they have to do more than what
they're doing there is an argument the
Europeans make and there's some validity
to it that because they have a much
larger welfare state at least some of
them do and a much larger scope of
spending by the government that they
have larger automatic stabilizers which
are essentially the automatic
counter-cyclical aspects of fiscal
policy revenues dropping at in a time of
contraction and expenditures increasing
in a time of contraction without the
government doing anything just happens
automatically so they're right to some
extent the European countries do have
larger automatic stabilizers but they're
a small portion of what what is needed
so they really do need a more
substantial commitment in a range of one
or two or three percentage points of GDP
and fiscal stimulus which means
basically increasing the size of the
deficit or reducing the size of the
budget surplus in those country few
countries that have a surplus so my
guess is they will get their act
together but it takes some time with 27
countries I mean one example the
Hungarian government which is under an
IMF loan package we requested last fall
or this winter a very substantial aid
program for Central and Eastern Europe
something in the range of 175 billion
euros for the Central and Eastern
European economies the Polish government
immediately said no thank you we don't
need that we're doing fine
and the Czech government did as well
there are problems in the EU because of
its size its diversity that makes it
very difficult for them to agree on
anything and it takes longer for them to
do anything then say an American
government or British government and
that's part of the reason so
unfortunately the Europeans will suffer
as a result well hopefully things will
turn around sooner rather than later
thank you very much for being with us
here today and sharing some of your
thoughts on the EU and the ongoing
financial crisis thank you for more
information about professor Cameron and
his work please visit our website at
yale edu backslash macmillan report be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you